[Music]
hi my name is Oscar nandus and I'm the
chef of the combi here at Empire State
Building fish tacos are found everywhere
in Mexico taquitos the guys that make
the attack was actually like rockstars
you go there and like you have to know
the guy because there's always like a
bunch of people trying to get their
attention we can find a big variety of
fish tacos in the South mostly they are
like real Lussier north they try them
here at second we will feature in two
different type of recipes the first one
is a Baja fish taco and then we also
have another recipe that is called
taking shape so we're taking two
different recipes like from one stream
of the country to the other one the way
that we make your Baja fish tacos here
in to convey you need to have an amazing
tortilla we bring the corn we cook it
once we have the coin cool like skin is
breaking down then we grind it we'll
make a masa and then we start producing
or tortillas on our Baja fish we use in
Alaskan cod then we fortunate the batter
we use Mexican beer and
it comes out really crispy and delicious
then we create this cabbage mixture with
like sketches but it's basically like
pickled vegetables like carrots
cauliflower jalapeno and then we create
a poblano pepper Mayo which he gives
like creamy texture and that's basically
the biscotti in Chile we use in our
rockfish and that comes from Florida
thinking sheet which is a technique used
by the Mayans and basically we're at the
fishermen Annalee with different spices
and I will sear it we use spices like
Mexican oregano roasted garlic roasted
tomatoes roasted lemon arrows some
onions we blend it all together and we
we come up with this marinade that fish
we also use a little bit acknowledged
though that we have and then we will top
it out with roasted poblanos and roasted
o'neill's lime on the side that's a
little bit spicier than then our crispy
fish I think the tacos in the Mexican
restaurant is seen in New York City it's
developing really well I mean people is
putting a lot of energy and not just
creating something new was more like to
go back to the roots and bring back all
those recipes having to convey and
Empire State Building means a lot at
this point we're able to share the love
of Mexican food with a lot more people
this is the most iconic building in the
world and being able to be here is the
greatest thing that can happen
[Music]